read all the impact statements that were
submitted earlier
and listen carefully to all the input
here today and it is truly appreciated
that you took the time to stay with this
case
and to provide me with input i have
reviewed the pre-sentence investigation
and carefully considered all the facts
the case in the law
but my comments are actually going to be
very brief
because most of it's going to be in
writing
i have a 22-page memorandum that is
going to be attached to the sentencing
order
and why am i doing it in writing to
emphasize the fact that
determining the appropriate sentence in
any case and in this case
is a legal analysis it's applying the
rule of law to the facts of an
individual
and specific case and that is why
as opposed to trying to be being
profound here on the record
i prefer that you read the legal
analysis
that explains how i determine the
sentence in this case
what the case is or what the sentence is
not based on
is emotion or sympathy
but at the same time i want to
acknowledge the deep
and tremendous pain that all the
families are feeling especially the
floyd family
you have our sympathies and i
acknowledge
and hear the pain that you are feeling
i acknowledge the pain not only of those
in this courtroom
but the floyd family who are outside
this courtroom
and other members of the community it
has been painful
throughout hennepin county
throughout the state of minnesota and
even the country
but most importantly we need to
recognize the pain of the floyd family
not going to attempt to be profound or
clever
because it's not the appropriate time
i'm not basing my sentence also on
public opinion
i am not basing it on any attempt to
send any messages
a trial court judge the job of a trial
court judge
is to apply the law to specific facts
and to deal with individual cases
and so
mr chauvin as to count one
based on the verdict of the jury finding
you guilty of an intentional second
degree murder while committing a felony
under minnesota statute 609
.19 subdivision 2 paran1
it is the judgment of the court that you
now stand convicted of that offense
pursuant to minnesota statute section
60904
counts two and three will remain
unadjudicated as they are lesser
offenses
of count one
as sentence for count one the court
commits you to the custody of the
commissioner of corrections
for a period of 270 months that's 270
that is a 10-year addition to the
presumptive sentence
of 150 months
this is based on your
abuse of a position of trust and
authority and also the particular
cruelty shown to george floyd
you're granted credit for 199 days
already served
pay the mandatory surcharge of 78 to be
paid from prison wages
you're prohibited from possessing
firearms ammunition
or explosives for the remainder of your
life provide a dna sample is required by
law
register as a predatory offender as
required by law
and you will receive a copy of the order
and also the attached memorandum
explaining the court's analysis
anything further from the state right if
this needs to be said we just ask that
it be executed forth with
tenant has remanded the custody of the
sheriff to be transported uh back to the
doc or
whichever custody is currently holding
him anything for the defense
all right thank you we are adjourned
well there we are derek chauvin at 270
months
in prison is his sentence for the murder
of
george floyd he was given
extra weight in that sentence for his
abuse of position
of authority as he was a police officer
at the time and also cruelty